okay so raised by wolves is now out with
its eighth and ninth episode
these are the last entries before the
finale and there's a lot to unpack from
them
throughout this video we're going to be
going through our thoughts on the
penultimate episode
and also giving our theories for the
finale obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to check
them out yet then i highly recommend
that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for breakdowns of the full season
and please drop a thumbs up as it
massively helps us out without the way
this is the heavy spoiler show i'm your
host paul
no not that one now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so both episodes eight and nine
really center around marcus losing his
grip on reality
as he slowly sinks deeper into his
devotion of the mythic religion
juxtaposing this sue becomes more of a
motherly figure for the children
and i think that they're slowly setting
up that mother and father will be
separated from the group
and she will step in as their maternal
figure episode 9 is even called
umbilical
which is of course a reference to an
umbilical cord and it really feels like
she gains a parental role as she slowly
steps away from marcus and sides with
mother
juxtaposing this episode a is called
mass
a religious ceremony and this entry
shows his descent into madness
we open with marcus peeling off his face
until he looks like one of the bad guys
and they live
as we know the character is wrestling
over who he really is
and this even went so far last week as
having him fight the past version of
himself
marcus has been plagued with visions
throughout the last handful of episodes
and because of this he believes that
he's the chosen one and not paul
in psychological studies there's
something known as a messiah complex
in which a person believes that they are
the savior of humanity
characteristics of this even involve the
person with the condition believing that
god is in fact speaking to them directly
something which both marcus and otto
have suffered from
a messiah complex is often associated
with bipolar disorder
and the character's personality goes up
and down throughout the entry
personally i believe that we're watching
him having an identity crisis
and since changing the way he looks he
subconsciously tried to find something
that he can feel he belongs to
and thus has embraced the religion which
may be causing his hallucinations
he goes back and forth between calling
sue mary
and internally i think that he's
struggling with delusions
we'll get into all that in just a bit
though and since escaping the pit last
week
mother has returned to the ship in order
to fix herself
you may remember last week that father's
fingers seem to be communicating through
morse code
and in the first episode of the pair we
get further development on this with us
learning that
in some ways the character is reaching
out he signals
soul is the light a mantra of the
religion which later becomes the
password that's used to revert to his
old program
and honestly i've never been happier to
hear such a terrible joke
it's good to have you back now i believe
that after he was reprogrammed
father's true personality remained in
his subconsciousness
and through it he's been carrying out
certain acts emerging to take over
control slightly when he's most needed
this is why he left a rub for mother
last week and followed champion into the
forest instead of staying behind to help
with the burning church
he also threw an axe and mist which i
think was the character coming out
both he and marcus struggle with their
identities and both their true
personalities are revealed
throughout the episodes across kepler
mother uses a medical ai synth
and his brothers as blood bags and helps
her to recover from the wounds that she
sustained at the hands of marcus
i did see this guy in the trailer and
was wondering whether he would be the
hooded figure or not
but there's still a big question mark
over who that is and we'll talk about it
later in the video
now inside her stomach mother finds a
tumor that's actually revealed to be a
fetus
and we discover that campion managed to
program the synth to be able to bear
children
we did see in the first episode that the
liquid which exists inside her
is capable of providing an environment
in which a fetus can grow
and it's carried across here with mother
becoming an actual mother
i've seen those kinds of cravings before
i'm not sure if the poster for the
series was
actually giving this away the entire
time and though it initially seemed like
the promotional material was just
pointing to campion
looking at it in hindsight it does seem
like it was teasing that this fetus will
become the main focus in the show
is this really the chosen one who knows
at this point but yeah
it's nice looking back at this sort of
stuff now we learned that the mithraic
followed the blueprints to build her as
laid out in their scriptures
but they did not truly understand them
it is possible that campion did
and that mother was always meant to be a
protector rather than a weapon
throughout the season she's experienced
a range of emotions from heartbreak to
happiness and more
which indicates her true character
initially mother believed that she was
malfunctioning
but clearly she's starting to experience
genuine feelings
and i think that she will evolve as the
series goes on the scientist champion
reveals that her looking after the kids
was just a trial run
and if she succeeded in doing so then
she would be able to bear one herself
elsewhere campion jr is haunted by
visions of tally
and though we don't discover what causes
these i do think that they're either
coming from a gas on the planet
or the true inhabitants of the land last
week we saw some of the natives in the
wood
and they fled perhaps running from a gas
that's invisible to the human eye
this could be causing the hallucinations
however where this theory falls down is
that although two received similar
visions to marcus
when he was on board the ship now it
could also potentially be a virus
that was passed through the simulation
and due to the time that the humans
spent in it
some of their minds have decayed and
they're unable to fully comprehend
reality
something similar happened to mother
when she entered the simulation last
week
and we almost got an inception like
thing happened to her with her getting
inside simulation within a simulation
what
now where this falls down is that
champion 2 has seen visions
at no point in the series has he been in
a simulation at all
the third theory is that this is all
just a simulation in itself
and the entire show is simply a computer
running tests to see if it's possible
for atheists and the myth right to
coexist peacefully alongside machines
this would be
a bit disappointing and cliched i think
and with the show being renewed for a
second season
i can't really see that being the big
twist that they go for
however as we know with mother's own
child the show does have this motif of
trialling things first
before doing them but let me know your
thoughts below
now paul sneaks champion food in his
cell as well as a communicator
and i tell you that lad he really is the
best of us
he has the best name too marcus catches
him and his paranoia starts to sink in
as he believes that he and sue are
planning something it's sort of a
madness of king george situation
and since gaining his leadership
position he's started to believe that
everyone is out to take the throne from
him
i'm not sure if it happens in the
madness of king george to be honest
it just just sounded clever saying it i
bet thing's story doesn't come out with
this kind of crap
anyway campion manages to claw his way
out of his prison
and he sets a light to a tapestry in
order to buy him time to get away
during this however marcus is prying to
seoul asking for a sign
and thus he interprets the burning as an
omen from god
sue leaves the camp with the children
and marcus attempts to track them down
tempest has still been following the
trail of milk left behind by mother
however the latter's bloodlust begins to
take over and she lashes out
she returns to the simulation and then
learns the truth about her child
heading into episode 9 we joined tempest
as she comes face to face with her
rapist
otto tempest is of course pregnant with
his child
and just as she's about to enact her
revenge mother shows up and begins to
drain his blood
in order to provide for her fetus the
trio travel through the land with mother
making it clear that
looking after her child is a prime
concern even though she does still care
about tempest
they find metal shards with images on
them that are capable of channeling
visions
i think this signals that there is
intelligent life on the planet
i'm now under the thinking that the
house character might actually be one of
the original inhabitants of kepler-22b
which we see when mother touches one of
the shards also
is it just me or did this look like an
engineer's helmet from alien
anyway we already know through the
skeletons and creatures on the planet
that it can provide life to me it makes
sense due to what we've seen in the
series so far
that there is a higher form of life and
these were the ones behind the temple
structures that marcus is obsessed over
hunter is pressed against one but
instead of burning up he's fine
indicating that there exists technology
on it that can sense when someone is
pure or not
or it could actually be sol now paul and
champion
also talk about the pits and how both
the mouse and tally returned after
falling down them
this perhaps confirms that something
exists at the bottom
that can change life the mouse seems the
same but
in the case of tally we know that there
is something else going on
gravitational anomalies being in the pit
could signal that something is likely
controlling them
and as we saw they were there before
mother and father arrived on the planet
so something was likely creating them
it's even possible that these pits will
lead to other parts of the planet
i would actually love to see the
characters in the show journey through
them
as they now have a working ship which
hunter and father take
they could also have been created by the
giant snakes that we see
and who knows if we will ever truly find
out what they are
on board the ship the children find a
relic from earth that relates to the
story of romulus and remus
two children that were raised by wolves
which of course ties into the title
we discussed the myth throughout the
season and how it relates to paul and
champion
so definitely check out our other videos
if you want to know more
now sue and mother reunite the latter
reveals that she knows the truth about
her identity
they really bond throughout this episode
and it's clear that the secret is going
to be revealed to the children at some
point
ortho manages to reverse the transfusion
process
and he sucks the blood from mother back
into his body he takes tempest hostage
but she manages to get there the parole
officer i want to say parole officer
droid's head
and toss it which kills the character in
a return of the king's-esque
helmet-crushing moment
unfortunately his draining of mother
almost kills her child
but sue hooks herself up to her in order
to donate a pint of blood
we learn that sue can't have children
due to a bad miscarriage
and this is why she's looked after paul
which he views as being a second chance
for her
sue says that when things like paul are
brought into existence
that people often chalk it up to being
god and we actually see this reflected
in paul
who believes that seoul is the one
behind mother's baby
we however know from the sim that it was
in fact champion
i think that the baby will actually
further divide the atheists and mithraic
with both using it as a way to determine
what is right and wrong
the episode ends with further division
and lucius finally realizes who marcus
really is
marcus says that they're all sheep and
that all he did was try and lead them
back to the light
but lucius lashes out and stuffs one of
mother's eyes in his mouth
after researching these i've learned
that they actually emit microwaves that
fire upon eye contact
causing people's heads to explode lucius
stuffs this in marcus's mouth
but it's not as if it's attached to
mother so i don't think that it's to
activate
lucious likely believes that the
character is dead however
it's highly unlikely because of the way
that it works
now i think going forward marcus will
actually return to sue and co
and lie about being ousted by the group
instead
saying that he left voluntarily he will
give mother her eye back
and then order her to kill the methric
so that he can cover up what really
happened
however hunter and father will expose
the truth i
actually think that the finale might end
with marcus's death
i can't wait until next week and i can't
believe how quickly this show's flown
over
but what i'd love to hear right now are
your thoughts and theories so make sure
you comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and definitely check
out our breakdown of the other episodes
in the series which are going to be
linked at the end
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on september the 30th so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chapters on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you